FELICE FRANKEL: Hi, everyone.
I'm Felice Frankel.
I'm a science photographer
and instructor here at MIT.
I've been working
with researchers
for more than 20 years
finding exciting ways
to photograph some
pretty amazing research
and to visually communicate
that research for journal
articles, presentations, and
other sorts of communication.
Now, before we
start our course, I
thought it would be helpful
to go over a few things.
First, just a little
bit about what
we're trying to accomplish.
We'd like to introduce
you to a new way
to think about images of
your research, a new approach
in photographing
science and engineering.
Whether you're in
research or just someone
interested in
photographs, you will
find these approaches
relevant to your own everyday
photography, if you're
photographing small objects
or desktop setups or
even those quick images
you make of your favorite
dishes that you post online.
It's really about
making pictures
that are more than good enough.
Most of the photographs
in the course
will be on the macro
level-- closeup photography,
for items measuring somewhere
between 1 to 10 centimeters.
We're not going to be
discussing microscopic imaging,
although the principles
you'll be learning here
will still be relevant.
Now, what do I mean
by new approaches?
It's about taking a
step back and trying
to see your material
for the first time,
thinking about how
best to show what
it is to someone
else, to communicate
with images, to bring
clarity to your photographs
and an understanding of how to
communicate what is probably
some pretty beautiful
and interesting stuff.
And in the process, you learn
to see your material in new ways
and perhaps think
about it differently.
And this is what I would
really personally love
to make happen--
to eventually look
at the world in a
completely different way.
I'd like to encourage you to
fully participate in the course
by doing the
photographic assignments.
As you know, we all
learn so much more
when we try it ourselves.
So we've kept the assignments
straightforward and reasonable
to accomplish in a
limited time span.
And finally, I want to
encourage you to relax.
In many ways, making
pictures is about playing
and experimenting.
It doesn't have to be
perfect every time.
And in fact, I often learn
the most from my mistakes.
So just have fun
and enjoy yourself.
We look forward to
learning with you
and to introduce you to new
approaches in seeing your work.